I love the idea you proposed to try and
get money back into the market you said
look we should give everyone a thousand
bucks every two weeks use it or lose it
you know I love this kind of
conversation I love just to get into in
for the weeds and just be challenged so
one of the things that you and I
disagreed on before though at this point
you're you know like open to anything is
universal basic income sure and if I'm
wrong but I need to change my mind I'll
be the first to do it it is my distinct
pleasure to welcome to yang speaks the
Titan of entrepreneurship the owner of
the world champion from a number of
years back the Dallas Mavericks of the
NBA mr. Mark Cuban mark welcome you have
to put there from a number of years back
in there gents yeah okay
it wasn't that long ago man like hard
time and you guys were everyone's
favorites because you you beat like the
evil Heat absolutely that's amazing so
mark you and I met a number of years ago
back in the white house it was you me
Daymond John and some other
entrepreneurs and fast forward and here
we are in like the midst of the greatest
crisis certainly that I can remember and
I have to say hats off to you because
you've been one of the foremost voices
trying to figure out how we can rebuild
the economy and I've loved so many of
your ideas I wanted us to talk today
about what the heck we would do to
rebuild the economy for the average
America and the average small business
owner I have been blown away by the fact
that you're on Twitter trying to help
people navigate the PPP that you're
trying to help small businesses and
entrepreneurs in any way you we can and
I am right there with you like I feel
like you're one of the people that
actually understands the gravity of the
situation we're in yeah I mean there's
no question look we're both investors
and companies and we see what's
happening to those companies you know
20% of them 25% actually are benefiting
from this because just change in demand
patterns
but the other 75% are struggling and so
I see what they're going through the
things I'm having to do to try to help
them what's working and what's not
working and the least I can do is try to
help others in similar circumstances
well I have to say you've been a voice
of urgency
which I love and appreciate because it
is urgent
you know we've lost 40 million jobs that
we know about and the economists that
I'd have dug into this think that 40
percent of those jobs are gone for good
we're talking about 16 million jobs gone
and the Great Recession cost us eight
point eight million jobs at the trough
so you're looking at almost two times
the Great Recession in perpetuity that's
what frightens me the most yeah it's
scary as hell I mean so if you look at
job creation right historically I think
either one of us would have said you
know leave it to the market you know we
can create X number of hundreds of
thousands of jobs per month X number of
millions of jobs per year but when all
of a sudden in a three-month period
effectively you find yourself with 40
million people unemployed 21.2
collecting unemployment on a continuous
basis who knows how many millions or ten
plus million are now underemployed or as
their hours or wages cut back so we're
in a very unique set of circumstances
well you can't go back to the old the
old ways we said just leave it to the
market you know or let's just do you
know QE and and just get more liquidity
into the system that'll take care of it
because it's just not going to work if
you and I and every entrepreneur started
as many businesses we possibly could and
supported every big business that we
possibly could
they're not going to be able to hire
enough people fast enough to really
ground swell of employment and and
change the game and that's what we need
to do we need to recognize we're in a
different set of circumstances that
we've never experienced before in the
modern era particularly in a digital era
and we have to adapt and we have to be
agile and and I think that's where I've
been pushing on I know you have been -
yeah that's why I was so excited to sit
down with you you called it America 2.0
and one thing I love about your
background is that you started out like
running a bar and in the
like you know you run like you brought
like real businesses so so it's not
always been like Mark Cuban on TV like
dispensing checks and advice broke as a
joke man I got oh when I moved to Dallas
I was living six guys in a 3-bedroom
apartment I was working as a bartender
at night I got a job at a software store
got fired and had no choice but to start
my own business and you know I was in
the same position as every entrepreneur
if I did sell something I didn't eat and
literally
my buddies and I my roommates knife we
used to go to the local grocery store
and we'd wait until midnight when they
marked down the price of chicken and
then we just you know the things that
you have to do but yeah I've been
through the fear of thinking my business
isn't going to make it I've been through
the fear of businesses not making it you
know we're the experience of business is
not making it so I know what it's like
yeah me too my first business flopped
terribly like I remember showing up to
in my case it was like the cozy sandwich
shop because they had like free bread
samples I'm just like today because we
go to the one place where you get one
beer they had all the fried mushrooms
and peanuts and all the junk food you
can eat and we'd have our one beer for
three dollars and just eat up so I feel
your pain you know so we understand
what's going on at the ground level and
you know the tough thing is like our
government doesn't have the systems in
place to really try and get to the
ground level yep you know we we set up
the PPP which you said fell short of its
goals for a number of reasons
yeah so to go through that on PPP and
conception was great right payroll
protection just one inch word says
exactly what it means if we were to
gotten enough money into the hands of
small to medium sized businesses quickly
enough they would have been able to
retain people on their payroll that
would have prevented those people from
going on unemployment which would have
prevented them from getting that six
hundred dollar extra stimulus but once
we didn't get that money into businesses
hands quickly enough they did go on to
unemployment and not only did that
create a set of disincentives because
you had 68 percent of people making more
on unemployment than they did in their
previous job and that made it you know
them not wanting to go back to work but
that delay also turned companies into
zombie companies where you did have you
didn't know quite when you were going to
get the PPP money you weren't sure when
you were going to be able to open or how
much you were gonna be able to be open
you didn't know what the sales or demand
was going to be for your product or
service if and when you were open and
you couldn't bring back your employees
because they were they're gonna be
continuing to get their unemployment
until July 31st so a lot of companies
are in this nowhere land that we're
doing ourselves in right now and so
rather than recognizing this is the
problem we're trying to just pretend
it's not a problem you know and look and
I don't want to make it seem like any
one parties and blame everybody's to
blame you know the Democrats delay
things they wanted all these different
fundings inside of it and that delayed
things a little bit the Republicans the
way they process it through the Treasury
Department made it so difficult for
banks that you know that slowed things
down and made them act like veins
instead of act like acting like they
needed to solve a problem and so nobody
right now is just recognizing we've got
you know 3.7 million companies whatever
the number is that receive PPP at some
level who are zombie companies in a lot
of respects and we got to address their
problems and most importantly we've got
to address the demand issue because
until there's demand for products and
services businesses aren't going to be
able to stay open no matter how much
money you give them
now and I love the idea you proposed to
try and get money back into the market
which is you said look we should give
everyone a thousand bucks every two
weeks use it or lose it it like
disappears if you don't spend it within
14 days and I gotta say that would be
one way to get us to spend all that
money I'd loved the idea like did like
because it would force us to to actually
not save because right now I think you
were the one who pointed out we're
saving more money than we ever have
it's forty eight fourteen point four
percent savings rate and increasing the
most it's been in more than 40 years and
so if everybody's saving money then
nobody's spending it and you know this
all comes down to confidence and ruin
you know people aren't going to spend
money unless they're confident that
they're gonna be able to either get a
job or keep a job you know there's just
so much uncertainty and the oh we're
past the point now of just giving people
the money we've got to get to a point
now where we've got to have people
spending money and get that multiplier
effect and what I suggested was that we
did a little bit to do a little bit
different than the stimulus checks the
twelve hundred dollars that we give
because people saved a lot of that where
they could but the one place that we
missed in that twelve hundred dollars
college kids you know they weren't
eligible for that those but yeah that's
all their money college kids right
because they have everything they've got
to spend I mean and and they're not
savers and so in what I proposed was
starting with college kids and
effectively the same eligibility
otherwise for their twelve hundred
dollars you would get a debit card and
that and they having a debit card debit
card goes to your point we have no way
to give funding to people right now we
saw what happened with the twelve
hundred dollars where tens of millions
of people had to wait for a check and
some were still waiting so as a country
we need to have an ability to direct
deposit to every citizen right because
if and when this happens again that
problem needs to be cured in advance but
I digress but with my what I was
proposing is a debit card we're
effectively a thousand dollars every two
weeks for two months
and you have to spend it in ten days
doesn't matter what you spend it all but
you have to spend it will tell retailers
you can't get cashback it when someone
used to the this debit card and then let
him go out there and spend where they
may if it's rent if it's food whatever I
love it man we should call it the Cuban
card popular man in in the country
because it would be like I just used my
Cuban card it does it does a little bit
um you know I had a similar idea I don't
know if this is complimentary one thing
I'm I'm deeply concerned about is that
thirty percent of small businesses may
close forever because of what you and I
are describing so I was trying to think
about ways we could get more money into
small businesses and a time limitation
on spending is one but I thought there
might be a way to actually say like look
this money can only spent be spent at a
locally owned small business like you
can't spend it on Amazon in the gang
yeah it's hard though right because
eight a lot of businesses aren't open
and bu you got a do you got a lip it's
hard to regulate what people spend on as
much as I'd like to see local businesses
again it's the right idea but once you
start negotiating where it's spent then
all the politics come into play so do
you allow this or do you allow that what
if your community doesn't have this type
of store for that type of store right
what if it's only a big national chain
and you're a small town in Texas so
again I think if you encourage people to
spend locally a lot of people will
recognize it now's the time to do it but
if you require them to spend locally you
get into all the political ramifications
and then it that just delays it and
speed is the variable we have to solve
for first I'm with you time is of the
essence one of the reasons why I'm still
convinced that the local spending can
work is that there have been some
college towns to your point that
actually have like ethical bucks or like
whatever the heck it is it's only good
at like you can't have local programs
that you make it available to support
right so whether it's Bloomington
Indiana box for ethical bucks or
whatever it may be georgetown bucks you
know saying yes we won't you can't get
cash back but we encourage you to
by your local barter currency right
whatever it may be and maybe that
currency gives you a multiplier effect
right we'll give you 105 percent of your
stimulus because these are only
available to spend locally I'm all for
that that's a great idea so so this is
money in people's hands and consumer
demand and one thing that you said we
should consider which I agree with is
just jobs jobs jobs like anything we can
do to create jobs out there in the
marketplace and so you've identified at
least a few needs that we have that
everyone can see hundreds of thousands
of contact tracers and people that work
at you know like actually identifying
what's going on with code mid-nineteen I
would definitely put infrastructure in
this category you know one of the
concerns I have is like how quickly can
we hire large numbers of people and
train them create a new bureaucracy if
it's done through the government like
because like you said speed is of the
essence but I agree with you
wholeheartedly that we have to
essentially do everything we can to drag
more people into the workforce and solve
some of the problems that we can see in
front of us
yeah because that's the key when you do
it for solving problems I'm not saying
dig a hole fill a hole right that that
complices nothing you know but you we
have programs like AmeriCorps right
there's 40 percent of the population I
read either has a vulnerability to probe
it or is in in the elderly demographic
right so there are forty percent of
population that's going to need help in
one manner or the other as we get
through this and there's organizations
like AmeriCorps which already are have
the infrastructure in place to hire
people the only issue is increasing
their budgets to allow them to hire more
so that that's for elderly in-home care
and support care you know and I think
that's critically important because you
saw what happened in New York right
there was something that came out that
said boy I'm as mr. statistics today I
don't know why but 60 it's because
you're talking to Andrew Young the math
guy it's like a row of the people who
had COBIT in New York 60% of people who
were shut-in at home who need Outsiders
to come in and help them they can't go
out and do for themselves and so there's
an immediate need that AmeriCorps to
train that doesn't have to be a high
skill job just have to be a high
compassion job
and you can create across the country
you can create millions of those you
know and that's a productive job that
enhances the the economy and really
provides support same with tracking and
tracing right now you're forcing local
communities and states to find out
what's happening and where and when you
limit it to States and there's no
federal standards
yeah the virus doesn't exactly adhere to
state lines and so you know how what
type of models you use and what type of
analytics do you use and how do you
compare those for one state to another
and how do you integrate them all so you
end up having be siloed that's of data
that may not be compatible the same
problem we have with healthcare right
now with insurance companies and States
and so having this on a federal basis
allows us to single eyes the data and
also hire the data workers the computer
programmers the analytical people the
healthcare people that can do the
analysis of that so we can track it
nationally and potentially even globally
and so those are the types of jobs the
same with testing right same type of
issue those are millions of jobs when
you add them up that are productive that
have a multiplier effect that have even
if they're just transitional they may
not be permanent at least give people
some confidence that they'll be able to
keep their job for a couple years
[Music]
okay so I launched a podcast and then
someone sends me an electric scooter and
then I ride it around on it and it is
glorious holy crap
ooh now he's like the Tesla of electric
scooters and I don't say that lightly
it's called the unagi which is a little
bit of a weird name I think it means eel
in Japanese don't iet rolls but this
unagi scooter freakin jams i gotta say
it makes just buzzing around so much fun
I've ridden scooters obviously unlike
those bird in lime and like uber
scooters and this is a step up from that
nothing against those scooters but this
thing is just better and cooler and so
much fun so if you want to see what I'm
talking about you can check them out and
get yours at unagi scooters calm that's
un AGI scooters calm and if you use the
discount code yang you get $150 off the
unagi
500 and holy crap this thing will change
your life because it's just so much
freaking fun like you just feel like
you're in the future like an episode of
Westworld
like just cruising around but the good
you know like the good episodes right um
you know what I mean it's also
environmentally friendly it's electric
you know you just go in someplace you're
not using much juice and it's just fun
as hell they send you this scooter in a
box it takes 60 seconds to put it
together and then it's one snap put it
away long charge goes like 15 miles
I was zooming around the neighborhood
it's fantastic
my sister videotaped me Andrew Evelyn's
videotape you you look pretty badass too
when you're riding that thing you know
well people are trying to figure out
what the hell it is at first because you
know they're like is that a normal
scooter and then they realize that's not
if you're in the market for the scooter
this thing hauls ass and is awesome you
nagi scooters calm UN AGI scooters
dot-com use the code yang get $150 off
for the you Nagi 500 look like a badass
feel like a badass like a magic carpet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this crisis is certainly to me cemented
the need for universal health care
system that is independent of employment
because if you have 40 million people
who don't have jobs and they still are
gonna need health care like we need to
make sure that you can actually still
take care of yourself you know my
attitude I'm not a fan of single-payer
right I'm a fan of a hybrid environment
and what I've always suggested and
actually I have a study that I funded
with the RAM Corp that were redoing
right now because of all the issues of
the pandemic but effectively it's a
safety net if you will if you have your
employer insurance keep it that's great
if you're on Medicare that's great if
you're on Medicaid that's great if
you're a CA eligible USA becomes the
insurer but the key element that makes
it different from traditional insurance
is that you don't pay any premiums until
you use the system so if you're 20 and
healthy or 27 is a better age and
healthy and you know you don't need to
use the system you're not paying any
premiums
I had it tested three times the savings
for individuals was sixty three billion
dollars a year and all those 45 million
people who are LTL chable would be
completely 100% covered immediately no
enrollment no nothing immediate coverage
you know and one of the things that you
see that I see is the epic inefficiency
in our current health care or delivery
and infrastructure that's how you can
save tens of billions of dollars just by
ringing some of the inefficiency out
that administration cost that's a
function of there being so many
different insurers and so many different
healthcare plans you know if you look at
Medicare Advantage there's twenty four
twenty five hundred different plans you
know that means hospitals have to have
administrators and coding elements for
every single one of those plans and
that's crazy and that's why I call this
thing the ten plan under the ten plan
you know there's just one program and
you pay Medicare pricing to the
hospitals now I'll tell you I'll tell
you the biggest game I'm Andru the
ultimate scam right now in health care I
turn into a healthcare geek so they they
have this group called med pack who does
all the end analysis
for how Medicare rates are set they're
being told that hospitals say they lose
money on Medicare rates the reality is
it's a great lie hospitals are not
losing money at Medicare rates they just
throw everything plus the kitchen sink
into their costs look at Toronto Canada
which has the Factor bleed not complete
single player but effectively single
payer look at New York City a hospital
in Toronto and a hospital in New York if
we lined them up all the cops are going
to be the same the costs for doctors are
the saying the cost for real estate
nurses supplies overhead everything so
the question I asked was why does
Toronto pay X dollars for a procedure to
the province of Ontario that Hospital
and it's far less than what it's not
your website two and a half X or
whatever it is yeah and they claim
poverty is something there's a
disconnect there somewhere in the
disconnect is because they throw in all
these incremental costs to make it look
like their costs are higher which pushes
up the pricing to all the insurance
programs which makes all of our
healthcare costs more and so if we get
down to the cost basis of what hospitals
truly paid and now is the time to do it
with all this reset then we can push
down the pricing of health care costs
significantly yeah amen no I know and
when you and I talked during the
campaign like you know you were talking
about how food insecurity is like a
major health issue in that if you want
to try and make people healthy you gotta
get good food and nutrition available to
them yeah yeah there's no question but
if you're not healthy will you if you're
not confident where you live if you
don't have enough food to eat you don't
have basic care then you're gonna be a
disadvantage to the rest of your life so
right now you have an entrepreneurs
approach to rebuilding the country
you've called in America 2.0 which I
then started running around stealing
from you you know create credit - if any
would ask them so so one of the things
that you and I disagreed on before
though at this point you're you know
like open to anything is universal basic
income which you know
that like that I ran on it and at the
time like you were not wholeheartedly
positive on the idea like would love to
talk through what your biggest
reservations were and whether or not you
still have those reservations or whether
you think that this is something we
should be looking harder at sure have
love to discuss but obviously I'm for
CBI caretaker basic income all right
100% for because that's a job and that's
the productive job that improves society
dramatically you know and I think we do
need to be providing economic support to
people who are caretakers for their
parents their kids their grandparents
whoever it may be stay at home and don't
have a traditional job absolutely
positively because the key element in my
mind and why I'm not a big fan of UVI is
the concept of productivity you know and
I I know this sounds awful but you know
to paraphrase the old john kennedy line
ask not what your country can do for you
but what you can do for your country
right I think for us to get through this
quickly or as quickly as we possibly can
the jobs that we pay for from the
federal government has to have an
element of productivity as opposed to
just choice now I'm not saying we forced
people into specific jobs every job has
got to be optional you can't you know
this is still the United States of
America you can't constrict people into
doing specific you can't be like you're
now like a road worker like a Jag
exactly you know if you want any money
no no not at all I'm not saying we get
rid of unemployment or anything like
that but at the same time I think we
have a very specific need to make jobs
that things we pay for it as the federal
government have some productive impact
and that's not to say under UVI all the
things that people do can't be
productive and aren't often productive
but it's not a necessity or a
requirement of UVI and that's my
hesitant C well so two things I'd say to
that mark and you know you and I like
agree on a lot of the big picture needs
open conversations like this are this is
how I learn and if I'm wrong I need to
change my mind I'll be the first to do
it yeah and I know that about you too
so I think I couldn't agree with you
more that if you're like
stay-at-home mom or someone who is
taking care of your aging relative it's
like we need to get you basic support
and probably the person you're taking
care of one hesitancy I have about
having the this definition of
productivity baked into whether or not
you get this income like I feel like our
government may not be the best arbiter
of what isn't isn't productive and if
you were to take let's say even one of
us like at some point our
entrepreneurial past like our parents or
whomever would be like that's wholly
unproductive or whatever you're doing
because they think that are like you
know our business is never gonna work or
a rock band is never gonna work out or
whatever happens to be yeah I mean
there's no question look again there
there are there's value to any income
any money that you make available to
somebody no question about it and people
will use it differently but where we are
right now again timing is the critical
variable and so for where we are we need
I would rather as inefficient and awful
and terrible and ineffective as
government is this is really just a mass
play right it you know it's it's a
scattershot and see what sticks and we
are which is what they did in the New
Deal during the Great Depression it's
not like they had some brilliant plan or
like we do all this stuff they were like
let's just do everything right and you
try to make your wins big wins and your
losses little losses and you know I want
there's nobody right now that I get
excited about in government who's
capable of this maybe you can be that
guy maybe I'll be that guy maybe
together we'll be that guy or together
man we'll be like entrepreneur Voltron
but to me that's what's critical right
and so you know in previous times you
know I would have I would have been more
open to the traditional UVI argument
because time it wasn't nearly as
critical you know we were humming along
but but don't you think pure ubi is like
the fastest thing we could do because
it's just like press that button I get
the cash out and I don't need to have
some process in place to figure out well
that's what I said but there's got to be
you know in my mind you want to have a
point where they say okay I've got to go
out go back to work right because the
other side of it is if companies don't
have so look what's happened
here's my other principle argument
against UV I look what's happening right
now with people who are making more from
unemployment because of the cares bonus
then they weren't their previous job 68%
of people are in that position yeah as a
fellow
yet they don't want to go back to work
and so now you've got these companies
that are unable to hire people and those
are the small businesses that need
employees now I recognize $1,000 and I'm
not talking I'm not saying that you be
our recipients are lazy or don't want to
work or anything like that at all but
just the economics of it are $1,000 you
know well here's the thing mark a lot of
those people aren't going back to work
because they have unemployment benefits
that obviously they went back to work
they lose those benefits right if they
were in a situation where they could go
back to the bowling alley and they got
to keep the thousand bucks a month like
I think that that's actually a hard
decision for them then the clear
decision of like hey you get this money
but if you go back to work you lose it
but isn't the extra $600 effectively
short-term ubi well and and that's
something like I would never have wedded
a $600 unemployment benefit to not
working that's a great point but still
the reality is like the 25-year old me
might or 21-year old me what might have
just said look my thousand bucks I've
got five roommates I don't need to work
and you know then the productive me
might not have been in society oh I
guess arguably productive me might not
have been society well and this goes
back to something else you've championed
because you're you're looking at like a
Swiss Army knife approach to what's
going on the economy you're saying we
should elevate the minimum wage to like
I have a federal minimum wage of $15
which I got the sense you were proposing
that across the board is that right yeah
because you got to make a show all
businesses play by the same rules and it
was meant to be for eighteen and over
only because you still want kids to be
able to get that their generations yeah
yeah but at the same time by doing if
when you have these transitional work
programs like the testing track each
Racine by paying them above that minimum
wage you also indirectly set the federal
minimum wage and the argument against it
has been it'll damage smaller companies
and smaller locations but really were
the negative impact has come from
is the variability between communities
and between states so you just go across
the state line and it's cheaper there so
people move there that's why it needs to
be federally driven whether it's
indirect by hiring enough people that
pays a lot more than the minimum wage or
it's direct and to the point where
anybody 18 or above the numbers $15 so
one of the things that I think helps
mitigate the issue you're describing is
like hey people will go back to work is
like right now a lot of these businesses
are paying very very low wages and so if
you're looking at like so I agree with
you that if you were like you have a
fast-food job that pays you like nine
ten bucks an hour you'd be like wait a
minute like am I really going to do this
work if like I'm not going to starve to
death in the absence of this job but
then but so it requires employers to
raise their game and I think it sounds
like that's one of the things you want
employers to do is to like just pay
people a living wage right but at the
same time you could go the other way as
well right you don't want to be
subsidizing that fast-food restaurant to
pay less because they know they're
getting the thousand dollars in UVI or
whatever that number is so it's like hey
you just turned 18 you're getting your
UVI come work for me 4x - as opposed to
I need to pay you of you know a living
wage so you know like for my companies I
made sure one of the things that was
that terrified me and would have
embarrassed me mightily is going through
the companies that I run in control is
if any of my companies were on
government assistance right because the
men I would make those fast food
restaurants that'd be like hey here's
how you access your welfare benefits
like you're like let's let's keep my
companies of ever having that headline
to me that's the ultimate socialism to
me where you know the government is
subsidizing my payroll to me that
doesn't get any worse than that
personally right everybody's got to make
their own decision with their own money
and so you run and in some cases it can
be counterintuitive from a UVI
perspective but you run the risk of
subsidizing those businesses for those
people are saying you want this job
here's what it's going to pay take it or
leave it
yeah I understand and I agree with you
on on a higher minimum wage as a way to
help get people back into the workforce
I mean we're looking right now so the
some of the ideas you've proposed which
I agree with virtually all of them in
terms of trying to employ people we have
contact tracing and healthcare we have
infrastructure which I assume you're on
board with and we'd love to talk about
what type of infrastructure what does
that really mean right yeah please
because there's infrastructure 1.0 and
then there's infrastructure for america
2.0 and so if you look at historically
at infrastructure you know you were
building highways between cities that
leveraged up commerce you build um you
build railroads and you build airports
that leveraged up commerce but the way
we've been talking about infrastructure
is just to improve those railroads and
bridges and highways and just you know
we moved the potholes because those are
made those are shovel ready jobs and
that's not a bad thing I think
infrastructure should incorporate those
but I think infrastructure needs to
think bigger and be more leverageable
because that's what previous big impact
infrastructure programs have done right
and so I think we need to start looking
at investing in robotics because if we
really want to kick China's ass we can't
do it by beach and you still the 1960s
right we're not first and we're not
first in robotics you've got Germany
ahead of us you got Japan ahead of us
you've got China try probably ahead of
us now and as a government all four of
those countries are making significant
and best investments yes
right we are doing nothing we've got a
lot of great robotic software companies
but we buy our robots from overseas and
the bigger challenge is just to create
an analogy let's just say there's a
billion products made overseas right and
we want and they're made overseas
instead of here because they're less
expensive to make there and we want to
bring back half of them five hundred
million products the only way we're
going to be able to make them less
expensive than company countries who
have don't have the environmental
protections and don't have the wages
that we have is through robotics
now the concern from a lot of people is
that that will to place displaced jobs
well if we do it on scale did the
economy that's built around robotics
will be dramatically bigger than what we
ever had in manufacturing recently III
couldn't agree with you more sound like
losing at robotics is a good jobs plan
is what the hub's it is yeah cuz like in
any business you always have to ask
how's your competition going to kick
your ass right and China Germany Russia
Japan etc they're not sitting still
they're saying America's not investing
in this so that's the exact right place
for us to invest because we literally
can get a huge advantage and to add to
this Andrew what I'd also tax robot so
like I have a company that I've invested
in and they do welding robots and they
charge the equivalent of a traditional
welder but they really fill in the
blanks right they weren't shifts that
they can't find welders to work there'd
be nothing wrong with doing the same
type of tax FICA type tax on both sides
of a robot if you will so that we tax it
at 12.4% both sides take nine percent of
that put it into the social security
fund or the general Treasury take three
point X percent of that and continue to
invest it in robotics as our future
infrastructure because we have to be
able to compete as a country and the
crazy part is we have so much
intellectual capacity and productivity
that were just not invested in right now
and that's our greatest asset along with
our entrepreneurial spirit yeah right
now the current administration wants to
believe it's 1965 yeah it's it's so
backward looking we need tens tens of
thousands of people to help install 5g
equipment and rollout
I mean like that's something we're
behind in we don't have like a native
supplier again software-defined networks
right because that's part of the problem
right we're so dependent on Huawei
because they came in and we're
subsidized and we're so cheap right
other nations are the same the only way
you're gonna build around that is with
software-defined networks and we need to
really look at that and like to your
point all across the country rural urban
everywhere you know we're gonna need
that to compete it's a great idea
you know we need we need rural broadband
I was in parts of the country that did
not have broadband access and that
struck me as yeah that's crazy you were
just like what's going on here
especially now because this is not going
to be our last pandemic or risk of
pandemic right there's going to be other
viral monsters that come after us in
some way shape or form or other issues
that occur and you made the best point
earlier and this you add the 5g to it we
don't have a digital way to communicate
with each citizen right we have no way
to put money into an account where we
need it we have no way to communicate
you know anything of any value between
us and in the rural environment it's 10x
worse right and so if we're gonna create
you know we're talking about going off
into you know how you sit around and go
okay what's the craziest idea I can come
up with the change things and so one of
the things builds off of your idea we're
having digital access to everybody but
having everybody have a digital bank
account doesn't matter yes I proposed
like a digital citizenship portal
citizen got us and we can just drop
money into account there and you just
connected to whatever account you want
absolutely and I thought that was
brilliant right now let me add something
to that whenever we go through these
recessions last Great Recession slash
hope it's not worse circumstances like
we're in now where the government bails
out companies or investing companies
indirectly let's just use we'll use what
Warren Buffett did with Goldman Sachs I
think it was right where he gave them
five billion dollars and got options and
warrants on top of that and when it was
all said and done ended up making 12
million it grossed 17 may 12th
what if that was the United States
Treasury doing the same deal what if we
then took all that right and divided it
by 330 million or whatever the
population is on that day and we
deposited one three hundred and
thirtieth million of each of that into
everybody's account finally for the
first time ever everybody will have a
pre shirbil assets and for public or
private companies you know just like
they tell you if you can invest when
you're young and have it yeah appreciate
compound
most powerful force in the world exactly
right now you get that same you get that
same progression right because the
biggest inhibitor to closing the gap and
income inequality is that the people at
the bottom live paycheck to paycheck
doesn't matter how much that paycheck
yeah
oh that the bottom 50% of Americans own
zero stock and so like trumpeting what's
going on the stock market's irrelevant
to have people exactly exactly so we can
change that so anything beep the the
Treasury or the United States of America
and best then that we were smart enough
to negotiate a return of asset
particularly that can be digitized like
stock or whatever warrants options etc
let's just split it up right and give
everybody their share now it with the
misty corner Society it would be
transformative mark just because
everyone would feel like they were
actually participating like it's right
now so many Americans feel like there's
all this stuff going on and they're just
like looking up being like what the heck
is happening whereas if you have an
account they could see the value they
can see it appreciate and one of the
things that like I'm fighting for is
like our data that produces value it's
like why are people not sharing in that
and that can get put into that same
account well exactly right you can
deposit anything in there you can
protect it now you know security
obviously is going to be important um
but yeah that's how until you get people
who are working paycheck to paycheck
till you get them appreciable asset
maybe it's a house you know that's the
topper but these digital these assets
you know shares the stock options
warrants that effect where we've all
owned anyways because it's our taxpayer
money that gives everybody a chance to
have appreciable assets and that's the
way to close the income inequality gap
crazy idea you know it'll take 50 years
before anybody considered this you
kidding man we're gonna get this thing
done like 50 years really get this thing
done at 50 days we're actually working
on the citizenship portal and the data
and the data property project you know
so we'll have like the structure set up
where all we need now is the government
put some money in the account and we'll
be golden
[Laughter]
well talking to you man it's like I wish
that there were someone like you like
and I know your your very loosely
affiliated with advising the government
on the response but but it is very
frustrating to me and many other
Americans where you see just like so
much ineptitude and bureaucracy and like
lack of urgency and lack of
follow-through and lack of
accountability I mean like for us trying
to get people money like we just
freaking cash app to PayPal and venmo
people because like that's how people
get money right now out of 20/20 and
then you have millions of Americans like
checking the IRS website trying to
figure out where they're gonna get their
money like the whole thing like most
people have still not gotten their
unemployment benefits or their waiting
hours just to apply you know not just
New York across the country now and you
and I thought the same thing mark it's
like why the [ __ ] do I have to call a
phone line to get my benefits like like
what is that about you get these like
stories that people be on hold for hours
it was like what is going on I know it's
ridiculous but look I mean you are the
only technically literate candidate
period end of story you know and here we
are in 2020 and that's just ridiculous
you know I mean it's it's inconceivable
and and unfortunately now you know the
candidates we voted on during the
primaries we didn't pick based on their
ability to deal with a pandemic you know
and so we're caught in this
never-never-land as well um so it's
going to be an interesting election but
hopefully everybody gets out there in
quotes yeah good out there and vote it's
the American thing to do so mark we you
and I talked about this informally
before but level with me how close did
you come to running for president Wow
was it like everyone against you or was
it like a split like against me because
they don't want to go through the grief
you know you know I I've got three kids
ten thirteen and sixteen my son Jake you
two dollars over very important ages you
know
yeah and it's difficult and and it'd be
brutal for them because everything I've
ever done in my life for better or worse
it would be a target you know although
my gosh you're right
all those drunk pictures of me online
rugby for god sakes in college there's
every crazy picture from rugby parties
you know that already got circulated
when it was just me discussing it and so
I don't want to put them through it
well your family is smart I certainly
missed you out there on the trail I
think you would have added a tongue
independent you wouldn't see me on your
trail I would have gone as an
independent I really would have I think
it's time I'm not a fan of either party
no disrespect for what what you were
doing none taken
[Laughter]
I just think you know yeah you ask
yourself as a entrepreneurs right you
ask yourself you know if things are
being done the same way forever
is it still valid that they don't you be
done that way definition of insanity
isn't it I mean it's one reason why
people are getting so fed up yeah
exactly so do we still need parties or
no if we have these parties and I know I
saw you're interested in elements of
democracy reform like do we need a third
party do we need rank-choice voting so
people have some flexibility now you
have this duopoly yeah I love
rank-choice voting I'm a big fan you
know people always ask me about another
party like I'm sure they asked you I'm
sure they suggested you run
independently the challenge is when you
create another party you still get the
same party dynamics it's just a
different party you know you still get
the desire for power you still get the
people who want to think they're in
charge and sets the agenda think their
agenda is the only way so as much as you
walk in thinking this is going to be
different it will be for a while but at
some point you get the same thing that
happens in in any organization where
power has it creates its own privileges
and opportunities and you just turned
into another party and so that's why to
me I'd rather do this as an independent
and you know honestly I did some polling
and oh I want to do this their way I
mean of course you would yeah a little
it's here yeah and so with independence
I'll be curious to see what what yours
turned out to be that in a threeway with
Trump and Biden I got like 70% of
independent but I did get I got I won't
give you the exact numbers yet because I
promise somewhere else that I've
released them but
I did good with Trump and not as well
with Democrats and I got about 25% in a
threeway and there just wasn't enough I
didn't see enough with the upside to
fight my family over it but 25% as an
independent in the 3-way know what that
would have been the all-time high right
what did pro get 21 like you have 19 to
21 or something yeah Arial right to be
honest we didn't you know when you do
these homeland you don't throw in all
the bad stuff about your candidate you
know you kind of play it up but you know
they lot that even with promotion
marketing and everything you know my lid
was probably 25% that's so interesting
mark I mean you have a persona where I I
genuinely think the bad stuff would not
have mattered
it'd be like Mark Cuban got drunk like
bubble butts like of course he did with
me my skin is thick enough right I own a
sports team everybody thinks I'm an
idiot at some point so I'm not worried
about that but my kids that's a
different beast you know my ten year old
still thinks that hung the moon half the
time well I will say I mean it was tough
on my family and my boys are too young
to know what the hell daddy was doing
they just had a bus you know so your
family you know family's wise but that I
think you as an independent would have
been awesome like I got to say like you
bring something very very needed to the
national stage and I can tell too like
you know like like you mean you and I
met at the White House because we're
just trying to do wholesome stuff but
like you're driven by trying to help the
country yeah yeah look I'm the luckiest
guy in the world Andrew I mean I don't
need another dollar I'm set my family
set their family you know future
generations are set so that's not
importance to me but I love this country
I'm not in this position without this
United States of America without every
opportunity that's been afforded to me
and I recognized I've been on both sides
you know my parents didn't go to college
until after I graduated and help them go
to college right and so my son pull
three on cars you know it's just you
know I've been on both sides and you
know it's I just like it's fun to me to
help
businesses that's why I do Shark Tank it
sends the message the American Dream is
alive and well and that you can come
from nothing and go out and start
something Daymond John calls it the
power of broke and so I'm at that point
in my life now that this is my way to
contribute you know this is my way to
help amen I'm like yeah and like I've
said many times you don't have to be B
leader to be a leader you know so
whether or not I do run there's still
plenty of opportunity for me or anybody
else for that matter to step up just
like you're doing right and you know
really bring topics to the forefront you
know really inspire people to do things
that change the game because when we get
to the other side of this the America
2.0 we're gonna look back in 10 15 years
and there's gonna be how many 5 10 20 25
world-changing companies that are
created because of the pandemic for 2020
and there's a better than 50/50 chance
that most of them are going to come from
someone who was down on their luck down
to the last dollar they had an idea that
everybody thought was crazy and made no
sense at all they went for it and it
changed the game you know if I can
inspire you know watching you when you
inspire people like that when will you
get out there and just make it a little
bit better why won't you do it oh that
that's the American spirit man that's
why people love you and your you're a
true patriot and definitely if not the
leader a huge leader and when we're all
using cuban cards with this thousand
dollar well you look great
and so thrilled to fight for america 2.0
alongside you mark you're one of the big
champions of where the country needs to
go and you and i need to help make it
happen absolutely i really enjoy you
have me on thank you for having me on
you know i love these kind of
conversations now i love just to get
into into the weeds and just be
challenged and to challenge people
because that's how we learn that's what
makes this country better and that's why
you know it's a bit always been a big
fan because you're always open-minded
you're always looking for a new
direction and you're not afraid if
somebody says they don't agree that's
that you're like me that's the person we
want to talk to that could be the
foundation of the new third party
right thanks so much mark all the best
of the family and be well
[Music]